[Música]
dentro de sólo unas horas colombia sabrá
quién será su nuevo presidente sin
embargo entre los más de 39 millones de
votantes un gran porcentaje no sabe a
quién apoyar o si votar del todo solo en
la primera vuelta a la abstención superó
el 45 por ciento
protestas en brásil decenas de
activistas e integrantes de comunidades
indígenas se congregaron en sao paulo
para pedir justicia por la muerte del
periodista don phillips y el indigenista
bruno pereyra justo después de que las
autoridades confirmaran el hallazgo de
sus cuerpos
en eeuu los más pequeños se abran podrán
recibir la vacuna contra el kobe 19
el cdc dio luz verde a la medida para
menores de entre los 6 meses y los 5
años de edad y que beneficiaría a cerca
de 18 millones de niños y niñas
hola y bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en colombia a unas
horas de la segunda vuelta de las
presidenciales muchos votantes aún no
saben a quién elegir algo que convierte
la carrera por la casa de nariño en una
muy incierta pues en las calles se
percibe un sentimiento de descontento
ante las dos candidaturas posibles la de
populista rudolf fernández o la del
izquierdista gustavo petro la
incertidumbre entre los ciudadanos marca
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en colombia en realidad
me siento muy desconcertada me siento
muy triste y decepcionada este país las
dos opciones como presidente no me
gustan absolutamente no voy a votar
porque no voy a dejar de ejercer mi
derecho estas elecciones son
probablemente una de las más polarizadas
en la historia del país esto porque los
candidatos gustavo petro y rodolfo
hernández representan opciones
totalmente diferentes de lo que no dudan
en calificar será un cambio y aunque
prometen reformas radicales en un país
que padece de una creciente pobreza un
aumento en los indicios de violencia y
otros problemas en las ciudadanía
también crece la desconfianza hacia
estas figuras políticas eso no lo
mantienen tan confundido de qué bueno no
sabe en realidad qué hacer sí porque el
1 adiciona todo se lo todo 31 se
confunde tanto que yo personalmente opté
por no votar un descontento que podría
haberse reflejado en las urnas de este
domingo según la registraduría nacional
el pasado 29 de mayo día de la primera
vuelta presidencial sólo el 54 92 por
ciento de los colombianos habilitados
para votar ejercieron su derecho
constitucional
situando la abstención en el 45 09 por
ciento la policía federal de brasil
confirmó este sábado que los restos
hallados de esta semana corresponden a
los del periodista británico don
phillips y del indigenista bruno araujo
pereira la noticia ha provocado
protestas en brasil donde los habitantes
condenan la violencia en contra de los
indígenas alimentada por el gobierno
los brasileños piden justicia con
pancartas que recordaban a otros
activistas medioambientales asesinados
los habitantes de sao paulo se reunieron
este sábado para condenar el asesinato
del periodista británico tom phillips y
del experto indígena bruno pereyra que
conmocionó el país culpan al gobierno de
la violencia contra los indígenas que se
ha convertido en algo habitual en el
país
este es el resultado de un gobierno que
apoya este tipo de barbarie y este tipo
de violencia es estoy aquí porque es lo
mínimo que podemos hacer para protestar
en memoria abdomen y bruno y la gente
indígena
otros expertos como bruno pereyra que
trabajan para la fundación nacional
india de brasil denuncian la falta de
protección para las personas indignas
no podemos trabajar con miedo el miedo
de estar en el campo y sentirse
abandonado estar en la oficina siendo
perseguidos también basta ya con esto
basta este gobierno fue elegido diciendo
que le daría un golpe a la funai que no
iban a demarcar ninguna tierra indígena
ni un centímetro más de tierra indígena
el asesinato de nuestros compañeros es
sólo la punta del iceberg
el experto pereira y ya había recibido
amenazas por sus denuncias contra
organizaciones que se dedican al
narcotráfico la pesca y caza ilegal en
las reservas indígenas del vale do
javarí la policía ha detenido hasta
ahora un pescador que confesó haber
matado a los dos hombres su hermano
también está bajo custodia y este sábado
se detuvo a un tercer sospechoso
en méxico muchos migrantes están
obteniendo visas para moverse por el
país durante 30 días en su intento de
llegar estados unidos huyendo de la
violencia pero en este éxodo terminan en
manos de bandas criminales en un estigma
especialmente violento contra la
población lgtb teis
maría josé gómez y roselli se enfrentan
a una doble discriminación
la xenofobia del migrante y la
homofóbica de la población lgp proceden
de venezuela vivieron en colombia y
llegaron a hace unas semanas a tapachula
en méxico duramos tres meses
golpes maltratos en barranquilla luego
nos quedamos a votar
en bogotá también recibimos golpes
nos maltrataron nos golpearon nos
señalaron
obtuvieron una visa de instituto
nacional de migración que les permite
moverse durante 30 días en mexico con
ella se movieron hasta la frontera con
eeuu pero las bandas criminales las
devolvieron a monterrey donde están
atrapadas tienen para eso
y para trabajos para la venta de parte
de hamas
el instituto nacional de migración
mexicano ha emitido siete mil documentos
temporales en un esfuerzo por frenar el
éxodo méxico y eeuu tienen interés en
evitar las imágenes caóticas de miles de
personas que llegan a la vez sin embargo
quedar varados en méxico sin poder
alcanzar el sueño migratorio suele ser
en condiciones crueles
las personas que intentan viajar al
norte a menudo huyen de la violencia y
la persecución realmente horrible de sus
países de orígenes luchan por obtener
protección cuando ingresan en mexico se
ven obligados a esperar durante meses e
incluso años en condiciones realmente
terribles jones en 2021 méxico terminó
el año como el periodo con más
extranjeros detenidos con más de 250 mil
migrantes y hablando de migración el
realizador colombiano jose alejandro
gonzález lanza su segundo largometraje
titulado álvaro y que sigue durante
varios años la historia de un
compatriota suyo que dejó todo en su
país para vivir el sueño americano más
temprano hablamos con el director y le
preguntamos de dónde le vino la idea de
retratar a un migrante y por qué escogió
este tema en particular
bueno escogía álvaro por que creo que
representa a muchas de las personas que
he retratado durante mi carrera
yo he sido un migrante he estado
viviendo en varios lugares del mundo y
siento que cuando uno se va pues deja
deja mucho en el camino y mi interés
artístico fue como adentrarme en la vida
de este hombre me interesé mucho en él
cuando me dijo que llevaba 45 años sin
venir a colombia y la película
básicamente lo que hace es acompañarlo a
colombia y pues se da cuenta como de la
conclusión de que ya no es como en
ningún lugar creo que es un tema muy
humano que nos toca a todos y estoy muy
contento de lanzarla acá en colombia por
fin llevar en eeuu todos los niños entre
los 6 meses y los 5 años de edad podrán
vacunarse contra el cob y 19 así lo
decidieron por unanimidad los centros
para el control y la prevención de
enfermedades cdc por sus siglas en
inglés la medida beneficiaría a cerca de
18 millones de niños y niñas además
termina por cubrir al último grupo
poblacional que no podía vacunarse sin
embargo falta ver cuántos realmente
reciben la dosis
[Música]
cualquiera que tome una decisión
importante sobre cualquier cosa
especialmente para sus hijos quiere
considerar ese equilibrio
si no sabemos todo lo que hay que saber
sobre esto y si los datos pueden cambiar
pero aquí tenemos una conclusión que es
que esta infección mata a los niños y
tenemos la oportunidad de prevenir esto
y todos los padres querrán considerar es
el cálculo también en chile- expertos
están trabajando en una solución
innovadora para combatir la desnutrición
especialmente entre los niños impresoras
de alimentos están utilizando para
diseñar comida que sea a la vez
atractiva y nutritiva informe de amd
albert alga papas y agua caliente estos
son los tres ingredientes de un menú que
según sus creadores debería revolucionar
el mercado de la alimentación infantil
el alimento fue desarrollado por un
profesor de la universidad de chile y
sus estudiantes típicamente uno cuando
figura distinta tiene una divertida
segunda
ser consumida ahora el punto de vista
que le llaman construcción alimentos
organolépticos visual los colores el
gusto también los sabores los colores
pero principalmente también nos
focalizamos mucho en la parte
nutricional el alga cochayuyo
deshidratada es el ingrediente principal
de la receta se pica se muele y se
mezcla con puré de papas se añade agua
caliente para crear una sustancia
gelatinosa que se introduce en la
impresora siete minutos después la
comida se imprime lista para el consumo
en chile y no solamente
una gran cantidad aminoácido y una gran
cantidad de minerales de hecho tiene un
gran aporte de yodo del coche
[Música]
el proyecto lleva dos años en desarrollo
y aún está en sus primeras fases además
de chile se está desarrollando en otros
países y mientras que las naciones
unidas se estiman que más del 10 por
ciento de la población mundial sufre de
desnutrición crónica algas como el
cochayuyo parecen ofrecer un potencial
nutricional altamente necesario hasta
que es informativo en france 24 gracias
por acompañarnos continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]